brutaler angriff mitten in der hamburger
city dort haben am samstag mehrere junge
männer sechs personen einer israel
mahnwache wüst beschimpft als einer der
teilnehmer der mahnwache sie zur rede
stellt eskaliert die situation
michael t erleidet brutale schläge ins
gesicht der 60 jährige wurde mit einem
jochbeinbruch ins krankenhaus gebracht
und wir konnten gestern abend mit dem
mann der die jungen täter konfrontiert
hat telefonieren dem mann der opfer von
judenhass hier in deutschland geworden
ist michael t wir haben seinen namen
geändert um ihn zu schützen und wir
wollten als erstes von ihm wissen was da
ganz genau passiert ist
ja also ich habe ich wie alle 14 tage in
der regel so mahnwache für israel mit
meiner mutter getroffen wir haben uns
nett unterhalten mit den mit hat man
demonstranten in anführungsstrichen
gehalt
israel solidarität
zeigen wollen und dann haben wir gesehen
dass zwei jugendliche die rolltreppen
rausfahren und von dem bahnhof betreten
und sturm ein liebes mädchen war auch
dabei sie blieben dann in höhe des
saturn eingang stehen und riechen dann
erst einmal als juden dann free
palästina und ich fick deine mutter dann
ging ich langsam zu den allen mit dem
kapuzenpulli abgefragt was hast du
gesagt und dann bekam ich von dem
lockenkopf mit dem pulse t shirt das
ausbilden auch festhalten ist von rechts
ins eck ins gesicht auf die brille
brille zerbrach das bedeutet ich ging
sofort zu boden und
blutüberströmt und kamen dann jemand zu
hilfe haben sie noch erinnerungen daran
wie es weitergeht
ja ich hab das eben versprungen in
erinnerung weil halt das echte musik zu
halten weil man vielleicht
meinen augen hat die blut aber ich habe
gemerkt dass die jungs geben ihm hat
ganz viele leute um die herumstanden und
auch in sachen bekommen haben was zum
beispiel ein kind bekommen ich habe aus
hunderte wort gekommen und die hand
gehalten meine mutter hat mich gehalten
und nachdem sie hinter gittern ich sagen
hatte hinterhergelaufen bahnhof und ein
foto von ihm gemacht hatte es gibt
wieder zu mir zu kommen habe ich
gehalten und ich mal gut überstanden
haben
wie sehr erschreckt es sie dass es
offensichtlich immer wieder noch einen
so oberflächlichen und gleichzeitig auch
tief sitzenden judenhass sie in
deutschland gibt
also es erschreckt mich sehr dass es
halt diesen judenhass weiterhin gibt und
der sich ja in den letzten jahren durch
sehr sehr versteckt hat das problem ist
ja aus meiner sicht und wie man das sich
mit zahlen oftmals wird das ist eben
nicht aus der rechten ecke kommt wie
viele leute meinen die sich mit dieser
thematik befassen sondern auch aus einer
anderen
ecke alle muslimischen apple gehen damit
mit juden nichts am hut haben und an
direkter du hast
es wird aktuell in der politik im
wahlkampf nicht sehr thematisiert fühlen
sie sich da von der politik im stich
gelassen
also ich mich absolut gelassen und wenn
ich du sehen dass die bundes bundesrat
jetzt nichts an steht es gibt keine
partei die ich guten gewissens
wählen könnte die ard ist für mich nicht
wählbar
die äußerung diese tätigen aber alle
anderen parteien was sie das bedienen
ist die fdp ob die grünen sind oder die
cdu die treue also wichtig das thema ist
ihm zu heiß es mag ein politiker
wirklich anfassen also an uns augen ihre
fehler wenn man etwas härter durchgreift
das ist durch freunde der heißt das
morgen von rechts das bild von rechts
gespielt und weiß nicht was ich dir also
schon nicht keine parteien in der lage
in das problem in den griff zu bekommen
ich halte vielen dank für dieses
gespräch das wir vorher aufgezeichnet
haben mir stinkt es war dahin bei uns im
studio in der tat in diesem wahlkampf
ein thema das nicht wirklich
thematisiert wird
antisemitismus darf in deutschland
keinen platz haben ja das wird immer
wieder gesagt aber auch islamistisch
motivierter antisemitismus ist ein
gigant thema das nun versucht zu den
schiffen
das problem ist erstmal waren das sehr
bewegende worte ich das ja ganz schlimm
wenn man sowas hört
schwer darauf zu reagieren auch was der
mann empfunden haben muss furchtbar
das problem ist worthülsen gibt es in
der politik ja ganz viele wir müssen
gegen antisemitismus aufstehen denn
werden wieder mahnwachen gemacht und die
politiker und laufen dort vor aber ich
habe das gefühl dass bei dabei auch von
muslimen angetriebene antisemitismus
irgendwie immer so ein auge zugedrückt
wird es wird immer so ein bisschen
gesagt ja das ist irgendwie was
kulturell ist das muss aber natürlich
ein ende haben und ich glaube wir müssen
viel viel stärker dagegen vorgehen und
da müssen natürlich schon konzepte in
schulen auch bei der integration
vorliegen und ich bin wenn ich sowas wie
damit bekommen wir so was wieder höhere
bin diese worthülsen der politiker so
leid diese floskeln wir müssen etwas
gegen antisemitismus tun ja dann tut es
endlich und vor allem fangt an zu
benennen und hat keine angst davor in
irgendeiner rechte ecke gestellt zu
werden aber du sagst es selbst man muss
ein konzept entwickeln in die schulen
gehen ist deine hoffnung natürlich dann
auch dass die nächste regierung da
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr ran
geht an das thema ich glaube es wäre ja
schon wichtig wenn es benannt wird das
wäre ja auch schon mal ein erster
schritt wenn da nicht wie du es
angesprochen dass thomas irgendwie immer
so eine leichte als würde man das jetzt
nicht aussprechen wollen dass der
antisemitismus von muslimen passiert und
das muss schon mal angesprochen werden
und dann muss man konzepte entwickeln in
den schulen und natürlich muss die
nächste bundesregierung mehr gegen
extremismus vorgehen nicht nur gegen
rechtsextremismus auch gegen
linksextremismus
wir können ja mal schauen wie sich das
in den vergangenen zwei jahren
entwickelt hat sieben islamistisch
motivierte angriffe gegen juden in
deutschland in knapp zwei jahren schon
einmal auf diesen zeitstrahl am 17 juni
2009 10 ein 20 jähriger in berlin
bespuckt und beleidigt weil er eine
kippa trug am 18 juni 2009 103 und 20
jähriger wird in berlin von drei
unbekannten ins gesicht geschlagen weil
er jude ist mai 2021 deutschlandweit
antisemitische hass demos gegen israel
15 mai 2021 ein 33-jähriger wird in
münchen ins gesicht geschlagen am 23
august vergangenen jahres oder ja diesen
jahres 2021 ein 18-jähriger wird in köln
zusammengeschlagen weil er eine kippa
trug weil er eine kippa trugen am 16
september 2021 antisemitische
hassbotschaften und morddrohungen gegen
lehrer in münchen und am 17 september
wir haben es alle noch in erinnerung ein
16 jähriger aus hagen muss in u haft
weil er einen anschlag auf eine synagoge
geplant haben soll es wird gefühlt immer
mehr
aber genau die beispiele zeigen doch
politiker müssen endlich über den
judenhass von jungen muslimen sprechen
es muss ein thema werden es darf auch
nicht immer verschwiegen werden aus
verschiedenen gründen man muss das ganz
klar ansprechen und dann ganz klar
versuchen das zu verändern aber diese
worte sind der politiker bringen uns
nicht weiter und wie die konzepte
aussehen in den schulen oder eine
universität mit schon bei der
integration vielleicht schon beginnt in
den flüchtlingsheim auch das müssen
natürlich experten machen das konzept
kann ich mich entwerfen aber es ist
wichtig dass es passiert hat mansur der
islamexperte die heute auch er in bild
dazu aufgerufen dass wir konzepte
brauchen und das ist auch ganz wichtig
als er gesagt wenn man keine konzepte
für alltag entwickelt wird sich die lage
für juden nicht verbessern und ich finde
das ist der richtige ja das muss
passieren wobei wirklich noch mal ganz
klar darauf hinweisen müssen
antisemitismus von jeder seite absolut
inakzeptabel egal ob von rechts oder
auch aus der mitte der gesellschaft
heraus und natürlich auch der
islamistische das recht thomas aber man
muss es auch benennen und das ist der
punkt man muss natürlich schon mal
durchgehen die letzten jahre und schauen
aus welcher ecke kommt antisemitismus am
meisten und das problem muss dann auch
erkannt werden aber natürlich
antisemitismus immer falsch also das ist
ja ganz klar
[Musik]